cette vidéo est en partenariat avec un
stand gaming
il vous reste moins de deux semaines
pour participer au concours du mois
pour participer c'est très simple il
faut aller sur le lien du concours
disponibles en descriptions et entrez le
nom du jeu de votre choix celui que vous
souhaitez n'importe lequel
et voilà c'est terminé bonne chance à
tous merci un stand gaming est très
bonne vidéo
la distorsion
entre les fans et les projets de game
freak commençaient à se faire ressentir
il était grand temps qu'un jeu de cette
envergure arrive dans la saga pokémon un
monde ouvert avec de grands espaces
qu'on a tous espérer voir un jour
bon j'avoue c'était un peu facile un jeu
flex un petit peu mais en même temps je
suis content 1 que voulez vous même si
nous n'avons pas parlé beaucoup de
pokémon sur la chaîne s'est complètement
la saga de ma jeunesse et par rapport à
mon moi d'aujourd'hui qui essayent de
décortiquer les univers de la pop
culture pour vous pondre de belles
théories baala je suis complètement
servi quoi une nouvelle lignée de jeux
pokémon de la série principale qui
épouse totalement tous le concept de
l'or et de légendes
que demander de mieux en fait évidemment
on ne peut pas nier que le jeu va devoir
faire ses preuves
et puis bah que nous n'avons pas
énormément d'informations pour le moment
quoi le trailer est avant tout là pour
annoncer le projet mais j'ai vraiment
envie de vous en parler et pas qu'une
seule fois à si possible s'il y a encore
de nouvelles informations etc
moi je suis clairement hype et par la
chose donc nous en reparlerons et tout
ça en plus ça me hype encore plus car je
vais pas vous mito j'ai commencé avec la
région de sinnoh j'ai commencé avec la
quatrième génération à l'époque et en
plus de ça je trouve que si nos c'est la
région qui contient le plus de l'or le
plus de légende fin c'est du moins la
région la plus attrayante en termes de
mythes et de l'or et puis rappelez vous
il n'ya pas si longtemps que ça on avait
fait 1 3 théorie sur
la saga pokémon et on avait pas mal
parlé de la quatrième génération
justement hashtag arceus bref il est
grand temps de démarrer je sais que
j'arrive un petit peu tardivement sur le
sujet beaucoup d'éléments ont déjà été
traitées mais à l'évidence cette vidéo
est purement subjective et reflète avant
tout ma manière de penser ce que moi
j'espère voir dans les jeux ce que je
pense qu'il y aura dans les jeux et
voilà quoi c'est ma vision personnelle
a vous de me dire la vôtre en
commentaire que le trois théories
commence
[Musique]
alors vous pouvez trouver ça un peu
précipitée et c'est tout à fait normal
mais laissez-moi vous exposer mon idée
de ce que nous savons du jeu les jambes
pokémon arcé us nous devons faire de
l'exploration et compléter le tout
premier pokédex de la région région qui
semble donc encore inconnu pour le reste
du monde et avec une base où nous allons
faire des allers retours cela traduit
clairement l'idée damas et les
connaissances les pokémon les
informations et recommencer l'aventuré à
chaque fois sauf que dans une cohérence
scénaristique
ce n'est pas une ambition qui nous est
venue comme ça du jour au lendemain
surtout pour des enfants nous allons
agir pour quelqu'un et comme le démontre
la tenue des protagonistes et les
drapeaux que ce soit la couleur ou le
logo
nous allons agir pour le professeur ou
du moins la personne à qui appartient le
bureau et qui va nous faire cadeau d'un
starter et maintenant il faut parler
logique et cohérent ce pour un récit
pokémon un jeu pokémon se traduit
toujours par la complétion du pokédex
une type de méchant un légendaire à
l'honneur et la conquête des badges pour
devenir maître de la ligue même si ce
nouvel opus se veut être une nouvelle
expérience pour le joueur nouvelle
manière de jouer à pokémon et bien il ya
forcément une histoire derrière tout ça
avec des personnages un élément
perturbateur
le twist bref paris si on ne va pas se
mentir ce que l'on semble faire dans ce
nouvel opus c'est une sorte de
colonisation de sinnoh et ce n'est pas
quelque chose de forcément bienveillants
lamy et de leighton en a d'ailleurs
extrêmement bien parlé mêlant histoires
et légendes
mais ce n'est pas ce qui va nous
intéresser spécialement ici dans l'idée
nous agissons pour le professeur dans la
découverte et l'exploration de sinnoh
mais qu'est ce que cela cache réellement
étant dans un récit pokémon et arceus
étant mis à l'honneur l'antagoniste un
forcément un rapport de près ou de loin
avec le pokémon pour un projet qui
garderait secret sauf qu'évidemment on
faire du mal aux pokémon c'est mal et
nous irions forcément dans le camp des
opprimés et donc des pokémon victimes de
la venue de ce professeur qui cherchent
à exploiter sino voir arceus récit
simple et classique des rpg j rpg
japonais mais qui fait toujours son
effet nous sommes alliés à notre ennemi
avant que ce dernier ne dévoile son
véritable plan secret ce serait
d'ailleurs un récit un peu plus mature
qui traduirait l'évolution de la saga
pokémon
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que le
jeu ce n'est pas simplement courir dans
les hautes herbes et appuyer sur une
touche pour capturer le pokémon non nous
sommes face à de véritables mécanique de
discrétion et de viser pour attraper les
pokémon des mécaniques beaucoup plus
élaborée qui salirait du coup un
scénario plus évolué de plus comme
beaucoup l'ont déjà signalé le logo de
la tunique des joueurs portage des
similitudes avec celui de la team
galaxie élément qui fait donc écho au
concept du joueur contre la team des
méchants comme dans diamant vers le
platine ainsi que les autres jeux de la
licence
et puis bon je le rajoute comme ça mais
l'utilisation d'un drapeau avec un logo
et avec des tuniques portant ce même
logo où on est tous habillés pareil
bah ça fait très empire soldats ou bien
envahisseurs pour ce genre de rpg
il est très dur de définir véritablement
le rôle d' arceus pour ce nouveau jeu
tant que nous n'avons pas plus
d'information il est difficile d'établir
quelque chose pourtant par rapport à la
nouvelle direction que semble vouloir
prendre game freak et le lors établi par
les anciens jeux pokémon nous pouvons
potentiellement considérer certaines
choses déjà maître arceus à l'honneur et
est assez logique est à la fois très
vendeur arceus est considéré comme le
dieu des pokémon celui qui a créé le
monde
celui qui a donné naissance à dialga
palkia giratina et tous les autres
pokémon de par sa condition de premier
d'alpha cette nouvelle saga principale
liés aux légendes se doit de commencer
avec arceus le dieu des pokémon et puis
dois je vous rappeler qu'il est l'unique
pokémon dont l'événement a été annulé
partout dans le monde
à l'époque de pokémon platine personne
n'a jamais pu accéder à la salle
originel personne n'a jamais pu
affronter arceus au sommet des colonnes
lens même si ce dernier a été distribuée
par la suite via des événements nintendo
personne n'a jamais pu profiter
officiellement de ce mini morceaux de
scénario de cette ambiance si étrange
qu'instaure arceus avec sa musique
et franchement c'est tout bête mais même
si nous savons que ça existe que nous
pouvons y accéder en trichant et bien le
fait que cela n'a jamais été
officialisée par game freak avec
l'événement casse tout le mythe derrière
l'histoire d'arqués us cela a été comme
celle et fin de l'histoire
donc avec ce jeu aujourd'hui ils vont se
rattraper et instaurer quelque chose
pour ce pokémon mis de côté depuis
toujours
par rapport au gameplay et au fait que
l'on soit dans un monde très vaste et
ouvert sans oublier la cohérence du
scénario et de l'univers pokémon déjà je
vous le dis il va y avoir des collectifs
soit des objets cachés a récupérées aux
quatre coins de la région vue car qu'est
us n'est pas un pokémon que l'on croise
comme ça en marchant dans les hautes
herbes
il va falloir le réveiller il va falloir
aller le chercher
certainement au sommet du mont
couronnées qui comme le montre le
trailer est une sorte de capitale
le point central et ultime de la map
dans la conception c'est comme pour le
château d'hyrule dans breath of the wild
imposant menaçant et gargantuesque pour
la quête de réveiller arceus et la
liaison avec le concept de monde ouvert
et se pourrait que les plaques de ce
dernier se situe aux quatre coins de la
région
un peu à la manière des coraux good en
bresse the wild
je prends breath of the whale pour
exemple juste pour que vous visualisez
bien la chose mais cela correspond à la
grande majorité des mondes ouverts et en
plus de ça concernant le mcg fine soit
l'objet central du scénario que tout le
monde convoite
alors c'est un terme de cinéma et bien
la flûte azur serait parfaite
imaginez vous à la manière de la master
sword partir à la quête de la flûte azur
pour réveiller arceus et l'affronter
dans la salle originel un artefact dont
je vous avais déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo car oui c'est un objet
rempli de mystères on ne sait pas qu'il
l'a fabriqué et caen et donc mieux que
ça encore et si c'était nous le joueur
qui avons confectionné la flûte azur
permettant d'accéder à la salle originel
après tout peut-être que game freak
avait tout prévu depuis des années cet
événement annulée car jugé trop bizarre
soit disant serait en fait lié à ce
projet
je légende pokémon
nous avons beau être face à une nouvelle
recette des jeux pokémon et bien ce
n'est pas un jeu 100% exclusif ce que je
veux dire c'est que proposait un monde
ouvert dans la quatrième génération
ce n'est pas aléatoire c'est même
calculé prenez l'exemple de bref the
void ou même final fantasy 15 qui est
aussi le premier monde ouvert de sa saga
d'ombré aux wade on retrouve les codes
la marque de la franchise
les références aux anciens jeux comme
les coraux goût le miroir des ombres la
master sword le château d'hyrule
les énigmes et cff 15 pareil on retrouve
le même vestiaire que les autres effet
le contrôle d'un parti de plusieurs
personnages des donjons les chimères et
cetera tout ce que l'on a déjà retrouvé
par le passé et avec un certain respect
des codes instauré par la saga final
fantasy est bien là dans ce que je veux
vous faire comprendre c'est que cela
sera pareil avec pokémon légende
arseus et ce sera encore plus accentuée
car ils font le choix de revenir sur
l'univers de la quatrième génération
ce choix pour moi démontrent qu'ils
veulent tenter une valeur sûre pour voir
le résultat
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'un remake de
la 4g va arriver quelques mois
auparavant
histoire de relancer la hype mais bref
donc un gros avec ce jeu nous allons
devoir faire face à un respect de tout
le lors instauré par les jeux d'origine
ainsi que des légendes déjà existantes
autour des légendaires mais pas que il
ne faut pas oublier que le but ultime du
jeu comme il nous l'a été présentés et
de remplir le tout premier pokédex de la
région de sinnoh ce qui sous-entend déjà
que si d'autres jeux pokémon légende il
y a ce serait plus tourner autour des
régions admettons un légende pokemons y
garde avec kalos mais aussi que
forcément nous allons devoir rencontrer
dialga palkia giratina les créer ithrane
très certainement chez mindark rails et
cetera
tout simplement car il faut respecter le
lors de pokémon existants et le devoir
de remplir le pokédex donc cela
sous-entend que l'on devrait parcourir
- brute pts la grotte retour bon je ne
préfère pas trop m'avancer sur le monde
distorsion car ça demanderait beaucoup
de taf de la part de game freak et il
faudrait justifier son accès sachant que
giratina peut apparaître dans la grotte
retour on parcourt vais également le
temple frimas pic avec régis l'igas mais
vu que régis gasse a besoin des autres
golem pour être réveillé
cela voudrait dire qu'il y aura
possiblement la présence des trois
régies également le paradis fleury l'île
nouvelle lune lille pleine lune
possiblement une réadaptation des
colonnes lens pour nous permettre de
rencontrer dialga et palkia donc les
rendre plus unique
en fait si je vous ai nous tout ça ce
n'est pas pour rien si le jeu se veut
vraiment premier degré comme nous l'a
montré le trailer concernant l'univers
de pokémon le lors les légendes ces
mêmes d'anti train d'ailleurs légende et
qu'en plus la complétion du pokédex et
notre but principal liés à l'exploration
eh bien nous devrons voir tous ces
légendaires et tous ces lieux à l'écran
alors oui mais peut-être que j'y entina
sera disponible dans le monde distorsion
avec un dlc comme d'autres légendaire je
t'avoue que tu nous annonce des
problèmes la tâche
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
et j'espère de tout coeur qu'elle vous
aura plu je tiens sincèrement à
remercier nage de m'avoir accompagné
dans cette vidéo ce bg tient une chaîne
twitch où ils chassent les pokémon shiny
c'est vraiment hyper cali un essai un
streamer qui est vraiment pour moi a de
l'avenir dans le milieu donc foncez voir
son taf tu écoutais bas n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à la chaîne a laissé un
petit pouce bleu un petit commentaire à
me suivre sur instagram c'est très
important sur twitter et puis voilà quoi
on se retrouve très vite pour du nouveau
contenu théorie n'oubliez pas le petit
concours un stand gaming c'est important
et puis que le lionheart soit avec vous
cet état gorak allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]